what's going on guys today i have some
exciting news for you which is that the
final season of attack on titan is now
confirmed to be having a second part
as of recording this video the
mid-season finale was just broadcast in
japan
and it was immediately followed by an
announcement that the next episode will
be coming in winter 2022
when they say winter 2022 what they
likely mean is january or february which
is around 10 months away
they do not mean that it's coming in
like november or december of 2022
because that's you know nearly two years
away almost so uh yeah it's definitely
not that
um so most likely january or february
possibly march if they're a bit delayed
but yeah that's likely when it's gonna
come we've now also had other official
sources confirming the news like
funimation
so we can say for certainty that attack
on titan will adapt the manga till the
end
for some context the final season has
adapted roughly 25 chapters so far
but there are still at least 23 chapters
left to go if we're including the final
chapter
which hasn't been released yet but
should be coming out in a few weeks with
that many chapters left to go it would
be a crime not to have a part two or a
movie or something like that
um so yeah i am not i'm not totally
surprised by this news but i'm glad that
you know we now have it 100 confirmed
up till now many people including myself
have speculated that there would be a
part two or a movie to finish off the
series
and you know the reason i thought that
was because the trailer for the final
season showed us
many things that haven't appeared yet to
me it always made sense that they would
be adapting those things in some form
otherwise that would have meant they
just put stuff in the trailers for no
reason which is just not cool
as many manga readers know the second
half of this season is
is probably going to be the best piece
of attack on titan we've ever seen
definitely it's going to be more epic
than the first half for sure and you
know when it comes to the final arc
that's not going to be easy to animate
at all but i hope the staff have
sufficient time to do what they need to
do
and you know maybe if the season is
delayed by like a few months i i
wouldn't think that's so bad
because ultimately you know we want to
see the best product
and this final arc is just going to be
so difficult to animate
so i really hope they just have enough
time let me know in the comments what
you think of this news
and be sure to subscribe to the channel
for more attack on titan videos i'll be
dropping my breakdown of episode 16
either on monday or tuesday evening
so until then have your notifications on
so you don't miss it and be sure to drop
a like as it does support the channel
until the next one peace out